BERNIE KERIK AND BLAGOJEVICH AND
MICHAEL MILKEN.
WE ARE ONLY 259 DAYS AWAY FROM
THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
WHERE, AS I’VE BEEN SAYING, YOU
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
I LIKE THAT PART.
AND TONIGHT, WE CAN REPORT
DEMOCRATS ARE IN A STATE OF
COMPLETE AND TOTAL UTTER CHAOS.
NOW, YOU’VE GOT BOLSHEVIK.
BERNIE SANDERS SURGING ATOP THE
NATIONAL POLLS.
HE HAS A 19-POINT LEAD IN THE
NEVADA CAUCUS, WHICH TAKES PLACE
THIS SATURDAY.
BUT THEY’RE WORRIED IT’S GOING
TO BE ANOTHER MESS LIKE IN IOWA.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE QUID PRO QUO
JOE, THERE YOU SEE HIM, SET FOR
ANOTHER EMBARRASSING
FOURTH-PLACE FINISH IN THE
STATE, NOT GOOD.
HIS CAMPAIGN IMPLODING RIGHT
BEFORE OUR VERY EYES AND
DEMOCRATS ARE IN FULL PANIC
MODE, THAT WE CAN REPORT
TONIGHT.
NOW THEY ARE ON TO PLAN B.
THAT WOULD BE BILLIONAIRE FARMER
MIKE BLOOMBERG, WHO JUST SCORED
A SPOT ON THE DEBATE STAGE, BUT
OH, LET’S SEE, ONLY HAD TO SPEND
DATE IN A
A MARKETING CAMPAIGN WITH THE
ZERO VETTING UNTIL THIS WEEK AND
THAT IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG, WHICH IS WHY THE PAST
THREE YEARS BLOOMBERG HAS
SHELLED OUT TENS AND TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGNS AND CAUSES,
LEFT-WING CAUSES, ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, INCLUDING THIS
SECOND AMENDMENT, ANTI-SECOND
AMENDMENT ACTIVISM OF HIS AND
RADICAL ENVIRONMENTAL USE.
NOW BLOOMBERG IS CALLING TO
COLLECT IN THE FORM OF
ENDORSEMENTS AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT IT, "WHAT MINI MIKE, OR AS
WE NOW OFFICIALLY CALL HIM,
MINI FARMER MIKE ON THIS
PROGRAM, IS DOING IS NOTHING
LESS THAN A LARGE-SCALE ILLEGAL
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
HE SPREADING MONEY ALL OVER THE
PLACE ONLY TO HAVE RECIPIENTS OF
HIS CASH PAYMENTS, MANY FORMER
OPPONENTS HAPPILY JOINING OR
SUPPORTING HIS CAMPAIGN.
WOW.
QUID AND A PRO AND A QUO.
MINI IS ILLEGALLY BUYING OR
ATTEMPTING TO BUY THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
THEY ARE TAKING IT AWAY FROM
BERNIE AGAIN.
MANY ARE CALLING HIM FARMER
MIKE.
MAJOR PARTY NOMINATIONS, HE IS
NOT FOR SALE.
GOOD LUCK IN THE DEBATE TOMORROW
NIGHT.
REMEMBER, NO STANDING ON BOXES.
DURING THE DEBATE, BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE SANDERS HAS ANY COURAGE
AT ALL, THE THINGS HE’S NOW
SAYING, HE’S GOING TO CONFRONT
MINI-MIKE, THE FARMER, ON THE
DEBATE STAGE AND ASK FOR ANSWERS
ABOUT HIS PAST, ARROGANCE,
SEXIST, RACIST RHETORIC, AND
YEAH, HIS INSULT TO FARMERS.
BY THE WAY, INCLUDING THIS
JUST-UNEARTHED VIDEO,
BLOOMBERG CLAIMING BLACK AND
LATINO MALES DON’T KNOW HOW TO
BEHAVE IN THE WORKPLACE.
WOW.
WHAT A BROAD, SWEEPING
GENERALIZATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS THIS ENORMOUS COHORT
OF BLACK AND LATINO MALES, AGE,
LET’S SAY, 16-25, THAT DON’T
HAVE JOBS, DON’T HAVE ANY
PROSPECTS, DON’T KNOW HOW TO
FIND JOBS, DON’T KNOW WHAT THEIR
SKILL SETS ARE, DON’T KNOW HOW
TO BEHAVE IN THE WORKPLACE,
WHERE THEY HAVE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY OR COLLECTIVELY.
>> Sean: THE WAY HE SPEAKS --
WORDS MEAN SOMETHING.
IT’S ONE BROAD, SWEEPING
GENERALIZATION AFTER ANOTHER.
IT’S NOTHING BUT, YOU KNOW, OUT
OF THE ORDINARY FOR BLOOMBERG.
REMEMBER, 2015, CRIMINALS FIT
ONE, NOT TWO, ONE M.O. AND YOU
CAN JUST TAKE THAT ONE
DESCRIPTION, XEROX IT, PASS OUT
TO ALL THE COPS, NOT SOME OF THE
COPS, AND SAYING THAT ONLY
MINORITIES WERE BEING ARRESTED
FOR MARIJUANA CHARGES BECAUSE HE
SAID THEY PUT POLICE, ALL THE
POLICE, NOT SOME, ONLY IN
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS IN
NEW YORK BECAUSE "THAT IS WHERE
ALL THE CRIME IS."
THOSE ARE HIS WORDS.
AND THE COPS, BY THE WAY, SHOULD
JUST THROW THOSE KIDS UP AGAINST
THE WALL AND FRISK THEM.
AND NOTICE, HE’S NOT SEEING SOME
OR MOST, HE’S SAYING ALL, AGAIN
AND AGAIN, WHICH BY THE WAY IS A
LIE ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE.
ALL THE CRIMINALS, ALL
MINORITIES, ALL WHERE THE CRIME
IS.
NO, THAT’S NOT TRUE.
TAKE A WALK THROUGH
NEW YORK CITY, MIDTOWN MANHATTAN
AND I’M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW,
YEP, KIDS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS ARE
SMOKING MARIJUANA.
NOT JUST IN MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
PLENTY OF CRIMES COMMITTED ALL
OVER NEW YORK.
PERPETRATORS OF EVERY RACE,
EVERY BACKGROUND, AND BY THE
WAY, NOT ACCORDING TO MINI MIKE,
MR. FARMER BLOOMBERG, AS YOU ARE
ABOUT TO SEE, THIS KIND OF
SWEEPING RHETORIC IS NOTHING NEW
FROM HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE BLACKS AND LATINOS SCORE
TERRIBLY IN SCHOOL TESTING
COMPARED TO WHITES AND ASIANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR JAILS, IT’S
PREDOMINANTLY MINORITIES.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE CRIME TAKES
PLACE, IT’S IN MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHO THE VICTIMS
AND THE PERPETRATORS ARE, IT’S
VIRTUALLY ALL MINORITIES.
>> Sean: TONIGHT, BLOOMBERG
VILE COMMENTS ABOUT MINORITIES
AREN’T THE ONLY CAUSE FOR
CONCERN.
HE’S ALSO ACCUSED OF MAKING
VARIOUS DESPICABLE, DISGUSTING
REMARKS TO FEMALE EMPLOYEES,
MANY OF THEM WHO WORK FOR HIM.
IN ONE INSTANCE TELLING THE
WOMAN THAT WAS PREGNANT THAT SHE
SHOULD GET AN ABORTION OR JUST
KILL IT.
THOSE WORDS, KILL IT.
AND THAT’S NOT ALL.
IN 2011, CAUGHT ON TAPE SAYING
SOME PRETTY SHOCKING THINGS
ABOUT THE ELDERLY, EVEN
ADVOCATING FOR HEALTH CARE
RATIONING.
YOU SHOW UP, YOU HAVE PROSTATE
CANCER, YOU’RE 95, YOU KNOW,
YOU’VE LIVED A LONG, NICE LIFE,
GO ENJOY, HAVE A NICE DAY,
LIVE A LONG LIFE.
THERE’S NO CURE, WE’RE NOT GOING
TO DO ANYTHING.
WOW.
HE FORGOT TO SAY UNLESS YOUR
NAME IS MIKE BLOOMBERG AND YOU
HAVE BILLIONS AND BILLIONS, I
DON’T THINK THOSE RULES WILL
APPLY TO HIM.
SOUNDS LIKE A DEATH PENALTY TO
ME.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE SMUG, OUT OF
TOUCH, ELITIST ATTITUDE, PRETTY
MUCH EXTENDING TO EVERYONE
EVERYWHERE.
BY THE WAY, ESPECIALLY TRUE
AMONG AMERICANS WHO WORK WITH
THEIR HANDS.
THE HEART AND SOUL OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
SUGGESTING, OH, FARMING ISN’T A
REAL SKILL.
YOU DIG A HOLE, YOU JUST DROP A
SEED IN IT, YOU PUT THE DIRT ON
TOP, AND WELL, UP COMES CORN.
POPPING ROSE, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE AGRARIAN SOCIETY
LASTED 3,000 YEARS, AND WE COULD
TEACH PROCESSES.
I COULD TEACH ANYBODY, EVEN
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM, SO NO
OFFENSE INTENDED, TO BE A
FARMER.
IT’S A PROCESS.
YOU DIG A HOLE, YOU PUT A SEED
IN, YOU PUT DIRT ON TOP, ADD
WATER, UP COMES THE CORN.
YOU COULD LEARN THAT.
AND THE INFORMATION ECONOMY IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
IT’S BUILT AROUND REPLACING
PEOPLE WITH TECHNOLOGY, AND THE
SKILL SETS THAT YOU HAVE TO
LEARN ARE HOW THINK AND ANALYZE
AND THAT IS A WHOLE DEGREE LEVEL
DIFFERENT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
SKILL SET, YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
LOT MORE GRAY MATTER.
>> Sean: YOU DIG A HOLE, YOU
PUT A SEED IN IT, YOU KNOW, PUT
THE DIRT ON TOP, LITTLE WATER.
COME ON, I COULD TEACH YOU HOW
TO DO THAT, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THIS IS SPECTACULARLY
IGNORANT.
WHAT HE’S SAYING ABOUT OUR GREAT
AMERICAN FARMERS.
MAYBE FARMER MIKE DOESN’T HAVE
ENOUGH, OH, GRAY MATTER, BECAUSE
HE’S SUGGESTING FARMERS AREN’T
SMART TO UNDERSTAND THIS, MAYBE
IT’S HE THAT’S NOT SMART ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW, THE LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION IN THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY?
HE’S THAT IGNORANT.
FARMERS EARN DEGREES, ADVANCED
DEGREES.
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITIES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ONE SUCH
INSTITUTION, CAL POLY.
THEY OFFER DOZENS OF AGRICULTURE
DEGREES.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
YOU CAN MAJOR OR MINOR IN
AGRIBUSINESS, BIORESOURCE.
AGRICULTURAL ENGINEERING,
ENVIRONMENTAL EARTH AND SOIL
SCIENCES, GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
SYSTEMS FOR AGRICULTURE, AND
THAT’S JUST ONE SMALL SAMPLE
FROM ONE UNIVERSITY.
UNIVERSITIES FROM COAST TO COAST
TEACHING THIS, BUT MIKE SAYS --
FARMER MIKE, TEACH ANYONE TO
FARM, I TEACH ANYONE TO FARM.
I WONDER IF HE HOLDS ONE OF
THESE DEGREES.
CAN YOU BE THAT BREATHTAKINGLY
IGNORANT?
UNDER THE SWEEPING
GENERALIZATION?
YOU KNOW HOW HARD FARMING IS?
YOU KNOW HOW HARD THE HYBRIDS
THEY MAKE TO MAKE IRRIGATION, TO
DEAL WITH THE ENGINEERING
ASSOCIATED WITH IT?
OKAY, IF YOU WANT ONE CORN ROW
TO POP UP, FINE, PLANT YOUR FIVE
SEATS.
SEEDS.
WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU HAVE
THOUSANDS OF ACRES, MIKE?
I WONDER IF YOU EVEN KNOW THAT
THERE ARE EXTENSIVE ACADEMIC
STUDIES DEDICATED TO THE SCIENCE
OF PERFECTING SOIL, IRRIGATION
ALONE, OR IS THAT TOO MUCH GRAY
MATTER FOR THE ENTITLED FORMER
MAYOR?
OF COURSE, BLOOMBERG, IF HE
WASN’T SUCH AN ALOOF, ELITIST
SNOB, HE WOULDN’T KNOW THAT
FARMERS ARE FORCED TO DEAL WITH,
LET’S SEE, MARKET VARIATIONS,
CHANGES IN WEATHER PATTERNS,
CROP DISEASES.
OH, MAYBE THERE’S FACTORS IN
HERE THAT YOU NEED TO LEARN
ABOUT, MIKE.
MAYBE YOU’D LEARN WHEN YOU GO TO
THE STORE OR MAYBE YOU CENTER
THE STORE OR MAYBE YOU SEND YOUR
PEOPLE TO GO TO THE STORE FOR
YOU.
MAYBE THEY UTILIZE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL EQUIPMENT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED MACHINERIES.
SEE THAT MACHINERY THERE?
YEAH, THAT IT’S GOING TO ALSO
IRRIGATE AND HARVEST THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF ACRES.
FEEDING NOT ONLY THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF AMERICA, BUT THE
WORLD ABROAD.
I GUESS, YOU KNOW, MIKE MAYBE
JUST PLANT THAT SEED, UP COMES
FROM THE CORN IN ROWS.
I DON’T THINK SO.
BUT IN BLOOMBERG’S SMALL,
ELITIST WORLD, I GUESS,
WHERE MOTHER BEATS THE
HOUSEKEEPER AT SCRABBLE, MOTHER,
THE HOUSEKEEPER LETS YOU WIN,
MOTHER.
OF COURSE, SHE IS OUR PAYROLL.
MIKE THE FARMER WONDERING HOW
HIS GREENS WILL BE TENDED.
REMEMBER, HE’S MAKING THE
COMMENT, WE HAVE TO HAVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE WHO’S GOING
TO CUT OUR FAIRWAYS AND TAKE
CARE OF OUR GREENS?
BY THE WAY, IT’S NO WONDER THAT
HE KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT THE GREAT
AMERICAN AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
I HATE TO TELL YOU, BUT THE GUYS
THAT MAINTAIN GREENS ARE CALLED
GREENS KEEPERS.
THAT’S A SCIENCE, TOO, AND YOU
CAN GET ADVANCED DEGREES IN
GREENS KEEPING.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY GET PAID A LOT OF
MONEY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS, BECAUSE THE BEST GREENS
KEEPERS ARE REALLY GOOD AT WHAT
THEY DO.
OTHERWISE, THAT SURFACE YOU’RE
GOING TO BE PUTTING ON, FARMER
MIKE, NOT GOING TO BE AS SMOOTH
AS WHAT YOU’RE USED TO.
BY THE WAY, COMING UP,
BLOOMBERG, IF YOU’RE WATCHING,
WE HAVE AN ACTUAL FARMER THAT
WILL BE ON THE PROGRAM TONIGHT
TO HELP EDUCATE YOU ON THE
AGRICULTURE BUSINESS THAT YOU
JUST DISMISS AS DROPPING A
SEED IN THE GROUND, COVERING IT
WITH DIRT, AND PUTTING A LITTLE
WATER ON IT.
THAT MIGHT BE GREAT FOR KIDS AT
SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, WE’RE GOING TO PUT
TEN SEEDS IN THE GROUND, LET’S
SEE IF IT WORKS.
THAT’S NOT HOW IT WORKS IN THE
WORLD OF FARMERS, WHERE THEY
HAVE THE CHALLENGES OF WEATHER,
THEY HAVE THE CHALLENGES OF
VARYING DISEASES THAT POP UP,
AND THEY MAKE THEIR PLANS
HARDIER AND THEY BUILD HYBRIDS
THAT ARE BETTER AND SAFER, MORE
NUTRITIOUS FOR ALL OF US.
I HAVE A CHALLENGE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE MOB IN THE
MEDIA.
NOW THAT BLOOMBERG IS ACCUSED OF
MAKING DISPARAGING REMARKS ABOUT
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE, TRASHING
WITH THESE BROAD GENERALIZATIONS
OF MINORITIES AND MINORITIES
ONLY IN MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE ALL THE COPS ARE SENT
BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE ALL THE
CRIME IS, NOT SOME OF THE
CRIME -- HE SUPPORTED HEALTH
CARE RATIONING OR DEATH
PENALTIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND HE
INSINUATED THAT OUR BRILLIANT
FARMERS ARE PRETTY STUPID AND
NEED MORE GRAY MATTER.
ARE YOU GOING TO HOLD ANYBODY IN
THE MEDIA MOB -- ARE YOU GOING
TO HOLD YOUR PLAN B
ACCOUNTABLE?
BECAUSE IF DONALD TRUMP SAID ANY
OF THIS, YOU ALL WOULD GO NUTS.
WILL THE MODERATORS IN
TOMORROW’S DEBATE, ASKING MANY
OF THESE QUESTIONS, APPARENTLY
HE’S BEEN PREPPING ALL DAY TO
GET HIS TEAM OF HIRED
CONSULTANTS TO GIVE HIM ANSWERS
BECAUSE WHAT HE TOLD US
AFTER 17 YEARS OF SUPPORTING
STOP AND FRISK, I DIDN’T REALLY
BELIEVE THAT AT ALL, NO, NOT
WHATSOEVER, I’M SO SORRY I
BELIEVED THAT FOR 17 YEARS.
HE ONLY DID IT FOR POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY, CAN’T BE ANY MORE
TRANSPARENT THAN THAT.
ANY DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS GOING
TO CONFRONT HIM?
HEY, BOLSHEVIK BERNIE, THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO CONFRONT
HIM, YOU’LL BE ON THE SAME
STAGE.
AND I HIGHLY DOUBT IT BECAUSE,
WELL, WE MIGHT HAVE TO GUESS
THAT THE FIX COULD BE IN AGAIN.
NOW THAT THE DNC’S PREFERRED
CANDIDATE, THEIR PLAN B -- WELL,
THAT’S BLOOMBERG -- SO IT’S
GOING TO BE UP TO BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE TO TAKE A STAND UP
TOMORROW’S DEBATE, AND IF HE
CAN’T MUSTER THE COURAGE, IF HE